[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في برنامج نقاش فرانس 24
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر مثل ما تشاهدون على الشاشه نقاشنا
عن هذا الصاروخ الذي سقط على الحدود مع
بولندا والذي تسبب في سقوط قتيلين تساؤلات
منذ الليله الماضيه عن مصدر اطلاق الصاروخ
حذر منذ البدايه حتى لدى القاده المجتمعين
في قمه العشرين في بالي بانتظار التحقيق
ثم تحدث الامين العام للناتو ليؤكد ان
الامر لا يتعلق بعمليه متعمده دون ان يحمل
المسؤوليه الى السلطات الاوكرانيه بل قال
ان الروس مسؤولون عن الحرب التي ادت الى
ما حصل في المقابل فولو ديمير زيننسكي حتى
قبل ساعه من الان
يصرخها بان هذا الصاروخ غير اوكرانيه بانه
الصاروخ
روسيت هجوم مقصود وترجع وتقول ان يتعلق
بانفجاره عربي لصاروخ اوكراني ولا ترى
موجبا لتفعيل الماده الرابعه للناتو هل
وجدت نيه لاشعال النار بين روسيا ومنظمه
حلف شمال الاطلسي ماذا لو تاكد بين القوات
الاوكرانيه هي التي اطلقت الصاروخ بعد
التحقيق سعيد بان يناقش هذا الموضوع وما
اي في الاستديو طارق وهبي ومحلل سياسي
سعيد بان يكون معي من اكياف فولو ضمير ليس
جيلنسكي وانا ماشي
سابق استاذ في العلوم السياسيه وسعيد بان
تكون معنا من موسكو الينا سبولينا وهي
مديره مركز الشرق الاوسط واسيا في روسيا
اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع الى
مختلف التصريحات ما الذي قاله الرئيس
البولندي
ديانه
روسيا كانت تهاجم اوكرانيا بالصواريخ طيله
اليوم
قاطع في الوقت الراهن حول من اطلق هذا
الصاروخ
وما الذي قاله رئيس وزراء بولندا
زياده الاستعداد القتالي لوحدات المختاره
من القوات المسلحه البولنديه
ابدا معك هاني اشرح لنا شويه طبعا منظمه
حلف شمال الاطلسي حليفه لاوكرانيا بولندا
حديثه لاوكرانيا
يعني لدينا السلطات البولنديه ولدينا
منظمه حلبسه تقول
لا هذا الصاروخ ليس بالصاروخ روسي وانما
ربما يكون صاروخا اوكرانيا
حتى حتى اليوم يقول لا هذا الصاروخ ليس
اوكرانيا وان الصاروخ الذي سقط وقتل شخصين
هو صاروخ روسي يعني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تحياتي امين
بصراحه ممكن عنده
رئيس اوكراني موجود معلومات
من المعروف كان روسيا اطلقت حواليت
السعودي همم صاروخ يعني هذا غير معقول
ان روسيا الاصابه سياستها ارهابيه سببت
هذه الاله الحادث نحن بصراحه هنا في
القران كلمه مجتمع مع الاوكراني لا نعرف
بالضبط هل هذا الصواريخ مثلا روسيه وروسيا
استهدفت عمدا بولندا او روسيا
او هوائيه
والصواريخ
بدون قاصد او هذا صواريخ اوكرانيه
روسيه
بصراحه هذا غير معروف الان هو نحن ننتظر
بصفه عامه تصريحات الرسميه
والنتيجه من الاجهزه
حتى الموقف الامريكي لم نفهمها نحو ربما
انت في موسكو تفهمين الموقف الامريكي اكثر
منك يعني
الولايات المتحده في البدايه على لسان على
لسان همم
يعني كان الحديث هو ينتظر ثم منذ قليل
البيت الابيض يقول روسي في النهايه مسئوله
عما حصل في بولندا وبعد ذلك تاتي المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي متحدث باسم ابن
القومي وتقول لا هذا الكلام ليس فيه تناقض
مع ما قالته الناتو او مع ما قالته
السلطات البولندي يشرحون نحن هنا لا نفهم
الكثير
مساء الخير صعب
من تقرا رئيس سبايدر
ما بين العراق واوكرانيا وينسى اسامه
في الوقت الاخير متناقضه ولكن بالنسبه
لحادث هذا واضح انه صواريخ اوكرانيه وانا
استغرب همم
في اوكرانيا وهو يقول انه كان روسيه جميعا
اعترف بانها اوكرانيه من مضادات اوكرانيه
فاذا حدث هذا الشيء فلازم يحترفوا لهذا
خطا نحن في روسيا لن اعتقد انه هذا الشيء
كان متعمدا همم يبدو انه هذه الصواريخ
كانت طائشه ولكنها وقعت في بولندا وهمم
وعلى اوكرانيا ان تقدم اعتذارا والتعازي
اقلب بولندا
وبراي اهم شيء انه هذا الحاجز قد اثبت انه
في اي لحظه هذه المواجهه ممكن ان تتحول من
همم مواجهه ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا الا
الحرب العالميه الثالثه هذا اهم اهم
هذه النقطه روسيا الان مع فكره المفاوضات
مع اتصالات اما للاسف اوكراني ترفض هذه
الفكره
اتفضل
لتصويب المشهد طيب ماذا يوجد في الغرب
الاوكراني هل هناك ساحه حربيه ضد روسيا في
الغرب الاوكراني لماذا تصل هذه الصواريخ
من مواقع اما روسيه او بلا روسيه او حتى
من مواقع من الدباس باتجاه الغرب
الاوكراني ماذا يوجد بالتحديد عندما نسمع
من وكاله الصحافه الدوليه ان 60% من
الصواريخ التي اطلقت البارحه ضربت اماكن
مدنيه وليس اماكن عسكريه الكل يعرف ان
الغرب الاوكراني هو الغرب اللوجستي بمعنى
القطارات القادمه التي تاتي بالذخيره
باتجاه اوكرانيا تاتي من هذه المنطقه اما
من رومانيا واما من بولونيا وقد نفهم ان
يكون للروس اهداف عسكريه في هذه المباراه
انا برايي ما قاله ما قالته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مهم ودقيق ان روسيا
تتحمل مس المسؤوليه الاولى هي ماديه
لاطلاق الصواريخ والمسؤوليه الثانيه
معنويه ترجع الى الرابع والعشرين من شباط
يوم فتحت هذه الحرب لذلك المفهوم
المسؤوليه لاوكرانيا
تدافع عن نفسها اذا كان هناك بطاريات
لصواريخ ارض جو فهي تحاول ان تضرب هذه
الصواريخ التي تتجه الى اوكرانيا انا
برايي الان نحن امام ما نسميه اضرار
جانبيه بمعنى ان هذا الصاروخ الارجو الذي
ضرب الصواريخ الروسيه لم يستطع ان يضربها
او ضربها ولكن ارتد باتجاه ال- ال- همم
يعني داخل بولونيا وعلى التحقيق الذي
تريده اكرانيا والتي تريده بولونيا والذي
ارادته الناتجه لكي لا يكون هناك اي مشكله
او اي لغد دي اي معلومه ان كانت عسكريه او
سياسيه
نصل الى ما نسميه ماذا حصل حقيقه ولكن
نقطه اخيره بالقول ان اليوم روسيا التي
تريد ان تصاوب لا ترسل 100 صاروخ يا سيدتي
الذي يريد ان يفاوض يجب ان يعترف اولا
امام المخابرات الامريكيه الذي التقاه في
تركيا انه له جدول عسكري مع هذا الجنرال
السفاح الذي ترك رؤوس سوريا وقدم الى
اوكرانيا لكي يرى الاوكران انه قادر ان
يلوي ذراعهم وان ان يسيطر على الارض لذلك
لنكن صريحين الان نحن امام منذ حتى لقاء
دول ال 20 والكل يريد ان يفاوت رغم ان
كعددا كبيرا من الدول كان يرفض داخل
البيان النهائي ادانت روسيا لفتح المجال
لماذا للحوار الدبلوماسي للعوده الى طاوله
السلام ولكن الروس بالمقابل ماذا جابوا
بارسال 100 صاروخ البال طيب نست ما قاله
الامين العام للناردو
كيش ليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان الهجوم
متعمد
ولا ما يشير الى ان روسيا تستعد لعمليات
عسكريه
ضيفه هنا في الاستوديو
اوكرانيا
اوصى من هذا الحادث همم
لازم ننظر لهذه الصوره الان من باب اخر
انه روسيا مستعد للمفاوضات الان روسيا
لديها اتصالات مع امريكا وروسيا لديها همم
اتصالات مع امريكا على مستوى المخابرات
وعلى مستوى همم مجلس الامل ايضا
واكرانيا هي ترفض هذه الفكره
فكانيا والقياده الاوكرانيه هل هي تتحمل
المسؤوليه على ما يحدث هل هذا التعندد
وهذا اللي اعتراض على فكره المفاوضات همم
يعني انه همم
يؤدي لتخريب اكثر وللتدمير والى اخره
لماذا لا نطرح هذا السؤال
اوكرانيا تعتقد انه ممكن ان تلحق الهزيمه
روسيه فاقول انه هذا شيء مستحيل هذا شيء
مستحيل حتى هنريكسنجر همم وزير خارجيه
امريكا السابق قال عده مرات انه هناك حان
الوقت لاجراء المفاوضات ولم نناقشه موضوع
الاراضي
ولا بد منه اوكرانيا ان توافق على تجميد
هذه المواجهه
على انسحاب من بعض الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لابد
طيب اين انا اريدك ان تتفائلي مع طارق لان
في نقطه مهمه يعني هو يسال
بما انه فتحت نافذه للتفاوض لماذا اختيار
توقيت قمه مجموعه العشرين لاطلاق صواريخ
على كيف على الفيف وعلى مدن اخرى هذا هو
السؤال
مناطق في العمق الروسي قصف منطقه الدنجر
على الحدود مع اوكرانيا وهي في روسيا التي
اجراريه يعني في عمق رؤساء التاريخ الرد
على هذا القصر نعم اذا قصف من قبل روسيا
هذا السبب اول والسبب ثاني اعتقد انه هي
رساله كانت انه طالما اوكرانيا لا توافق
على هذه المفاوضات
تدمير البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه حيث
استمر
مقرفه من السيده الينا اولا ايه اوكرانيا
استهدفت اي اراضي روسيه
في اي مدينه اوكرانيا
ولكن في سجن لانه هو مجرم او او في شنق او
بعد الشنط الان نحن هنا
[موسيقى]
اساس المحكمه جنائيه الدوليه حول الجرائم
قتل هنا في اوكرانيا او جرائم قتل في دول
الشعب من المعروف يعني الجيش الروسي
واطفال في سوريا في الشام يعني من الضروري
بانفوتي عسكريه والسياسيه روسيه سوف
تحاسب على كل جرائم التي
تقول كان روسيا كانت مستعده للتفاوض وان
رفضت اتفضل ارد على هذه النقطه ولكن ما هي
اقتراح روسي همم هذا غير مقبوله روسيا
ترغب اعتراف من اوكرانيا اراد المحتله
روسيا طارق بين اعظم الانضمام اوكرانيا
لجحاته روبي الى الناقه هذا من المستحيل
نحن بالعكس
الموضوع تعويضات وكمان نحن
محكمه عسكريه حول
ارادنا من اراضي اوكرانيه همم
فللاس في شديد بالمناسبه او الامس انفجرت
عائله النبي سياره في محافظه في رسومه
الحمد لله عاليه سليمه ولكن روسيا ارتكبت
جرائم حرب ومن ضروري بانها سوف تحاسب
لكلها بالجرائد
لمن يلمكروفون في المؤتمر الصحفي لابد من
وصول من الوصول الى قناه تفاوض ولابد من
الاستمرار في الحديث مع فلاديمير صحيح
فرنسا منى من اليوم الاول من قبل 24 من
شباط عندما بدات كل اجهزه
الاستخبارات تقول انك بوتين ينوي على
موضوع ما هو فرنسا تقول يجب الحوار مع
بوتين يجب الحوار مع روسيا يعني روسيا لا
يوجد الا بوتين بمعنى انه حتى الان يعني
كنت اسمع في التلفزه بوتين منذ منذ الخروج
من كرسون لا نسمعه ابدا اليوم تكلم عن
اسعار السيارات
في روسيا انها جد غاليه هل هذا هو الموضوع
الاهم في روسيا لا اعلم الموضوع توفيق ان
فرنسا والاتحاد الاوروبي يريدان ان يكونوا
واقعيين الواقع السياسي يفرض الان
كانت موجوده لانهاء الحرب قبل بدايه سنه
كان كان موضوع مهم ان يكون نهايه الحرب
قبل بدايه السنه 2023 ولكن بنفس الوقت
المشكله هي وضع الشروط التي تريد بها
تريدها روسيا يعني لا يمكن العوده عن
القرد لا يمكن العوده عن الاقاليم الاربعه
هناك من يطرح والسيد اا ضيفتك من همم
تتكلم عن كيسنجر كيسنجر هو ملك من يسميه
التقسيم وهناك من يقول ايضا ان هناك حلا
في اوكرانيا على الطريقه السويسريه بمعنى
كونتونات بمعنى ان كل الشرق كل الشرق
الاكتراني يزال داخل السياده الاوكرانيه
نتكلم روسي كما ذوري اخت تتكلم الماني
وجونيف تتكلم فرنسي واقليم يتكلم ايطالي
بمعنى ان اذا كان هذا الموضوع هو الموضوع
له علاقه باللغه لنضع هذه الاقاليم داخل
اوكرانيا ونحل هذه المشكله على الطريقه
السويسريه بهذا المعنى لكن المشكله ان منذ
اتفاقيات التي حصلت في بيلاروسيا على
الطاوله كان المسدس الروسي موجود بمعنى
انكم انتم ارتكبتم جرائم نعم اوكرانيا
ارتكبت جرائم في الدباس بعد الجنود وبعض
القاده الاوكرانيين الذين كانوا موجودين
في الدم بس وهذا موثق لدى الاو اس او لدى
المنظمه الدول الامن
في اوروبا اذا هناك مواضيع واقعيه وحاضره
في هذا الموضوع يجب ان نتعاون معه ولكن
الجانب الروسي ليس بواقعي الجانب الروسي
هو يريد فقط الهيمنه والسيطر على المناطق
الذي يريدها تحت شعار ان الاوكران كانوا
في الاتحاد السوفيتي وخرجوا ولم طيب كل
هذه الدول التي كانت داخل الاتحاد
السوفيتي وخرجت هي تريد ايضا عدم الالتزام
غدا سنرى في كازاخستان موضوع في كردستان
في كل هذه المواقع اذا علينا ان نفهم جيدا
ان لا يمكن لروسيا ان تتعاطى الا بمفهوم
ان هذه القوه الكبيره التي تريد ان يكون
هناك شركاء دوليين كفرا سكالي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كالاتحاد اوروبي
كالمانيا او حتى الصين لانه موضوع الصين
جد مهم في هذا الموضوع ان يكون في على هذه
الطاوله ولكن المشكله انه لا يوجد واقعيه
في هذا الحوار كيف تريد ان يكون هناك سلام
وانت ترسل كل يوم 90 صاروخ وحجه السيده
همم
هناك صواريخ اطلقها الجانب الاوكراني
باتجاه الكره كل يوم يطلق صواريخ في هذه
المنطقه الحربيه التي هي بالدم باص والتي
هي من اتجاه خارجي يعني هذا الموضوع همم
اطلق هذا الصاروخ ولكن لا ترد في الغرب
الاوكراني هذه هي المشكله يعني مساله الان
ما تروحها هي هل توجد نيه لاعاده بناء
الثقه بين الجانبين يعني ان اختلفنا عن
صاروخ من اطلقها واطلقت روسيا اطلقه فما
بالك ببقيه القضايا العالقه والتي نتحدث
عنها
تحت بشكل اخر تحت شكل اخر سيده سيده تحت
بشكل اخر ليس الاتحاد سوف يتسبك ولكن بشكل
اخر
فستان ولكن ليس لا تبالغ هذا شيء مستحيل
هو مسكت تفهم ذلك
فبالنسبه للثقه ما بين موسكو وكيل ما بين
بوتين وزلانسكي انا اعتقد انه في المستقبل
القريب هذا شيء مستحيل ولكن روسيا تحاول
بناء ثقه ما بينها وامريكا وهذا شيء ملفت
للنظر هناك مفاوضات حاول تبادل سجناء بين
روسيا امريكا هناك مفاوضات حول اسلحه
استراتيجيه واحاول همم استئناف همم
التفتيشات والمراقبه على رؤوسنا
ومستودعات والى اخره فهذا شيء مهم وروس
ومن وراء هذه الاتصالات ممكن ان تبدا
الضغوطات الامريكيه اعلى اوكرانيا لكي
تتقبل فكره المفاوضات وهي لا حتى الان هي
ترقد هذا الشيء وحتى ضايقكم من اوكراني
يقول ويكرر دائما انه ليس هناك اي مفاوضات
معقوده عندما هناك اتصالات ما بين امريكا
وروسيا الان عندما رئيس فرنسا ماكرون يقول
انه لا تسمع بازاله روسيا انتم تتذكرون
انه قال اكثر من مره حتى تذكر انه قال
ربيع وفي الصيف ويقررها دائما انه لازم ان
تكون هناك اتصالات مع روسيا لا بد من هذا
الشيء بس هذا لا يمنع ان لا يكون مع
القانون الدولي يا سيدتي يجب ان نفهم جيدا
ان مقامت به روسيا هو ضد القانون الدولي
والتلاقا من هذا لا يزال الرئيس مكرم
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكل الدول التي صوتت
داخل الجمعيه الامم المتحده تدين ما حصل
في اوكرانيا وبنفس الوقت عندما اسمعك ان
هناك اتفاق روسي امريكي وكانه هناك يعني
نوع من تقسيم روز اوكرانيا الى جزء امريكي
وجزء روسي هل هذا ما تريد منه انا
باعتقادي هذا غير واقعي الموضوع يجب ان
نفهمه من الثقافه من التاريخ المشترك ما
بين الاكران وما بين الروس وعلينا ان نفهم
جيدا ان اوكرانيا هي اقرب الى روسيا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالمفهوم
الثقافي ولذلك كان يجب على الاخ الكبير اي
الروسي ان يفهم هذا الموضوع ان يتعاطى
بهذه بطريقه مختلفه كليا عم ما نراه الان
وهذه التحقيق للرؤساء للمسؤولين في
اوكرانيا لن تصل الى شيء وهذه الطريقه لن
تصل لا بوتين وغير بوتين وخصوصا ان كل
الادله وفرنسا تشارك المحكمه الدوليه
وتشارك الامم المتحده بوضع كل ما نسميها
الد على ارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه في
مواقع معينه كانت تحتلها القوات الروسيه
هنا
فهذا هو الطريق
اذا كان حديث حول الكل هذا فهذا يعني انه
اي مفاوضات لن تؤدين لنجاح هون المشكله
ولكن هناك همم ناس عقلانيين اعتقد حتى في
دول الغربيه يفهمون انه عليهم ان لا يؤدوا
الامور لهذه الدرجه فهم لديهم اتصالات مع
روسيا ان شاء الله هذه الاتصالات حتى تؤدي
للنتيجه والا لا بد من تصعيد من جديد والا
لابد من اطاله هذه الازمه انتم تريدون هذا
انا برايي الذي فتح الازمه هو روسيا وهو
الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان يوقف هذه الازمه لا
احد غير روسيا يستطيع ان يوقف هذه الحرب
التي تدمر وتدمر وتدمر داخل روسيا ليعطونا
ارقام الذين قتلوا او استشهدوا بالنسبه
للجيش الروسي في ارض المعرفه لنعرف
بتحقيقه ما يحصل لانه حتى اللحظه لا توجد
اي ارقام حقيقيه وواقعيه بهذا الموضوع
وانت تعرفين اكثر مني في هذه القضيه ضمير
فيما يتعلق باعاده بناء ثقه يعني نحن
نحتاج طبعا لانها تتحدث ربما عن دول همم
فيها حكمها يحاولون الان لانه هناك قلق في
اوروبا قلق كبير في اوروبا من هذه الحرب
قلق لدى الشعوب لا تحدث عن الحكومات تتحدث
عن الشعوب يعني ونحن نسمه حتى في الشارع
الى متى سنظل نراها هذه المشاهد الى متى
ستكلفنا هذا الحرب التي تكلف الدول
الاوروبيه اعاده الاعمال على الاقل اتفضل
اسئله الى الزعيم
فهل كانت مفاوضات ما هتلر لا اكيد لا
روسيا اصبحت محور الشرق
[موسيقى]
يقول لابد من الاستمرار
في اوروبا
كيف سترد اوكرانيا بهذا الموضوع بهذا
الموضوع
جد مهم في اوروبا يعني الحاجه الاوروبيه
لكي يكون هناك
قرار او اتجاهات سياسيه جديده لدى القياده
الاوكرانيه مهم انا افهم حديثك بانك تنعت
بوتين بكذا وكذا ولكن ما هو الحل كيف
تستطيع هذه القياده الاخرانيه للوص الى
ما نسميه هل هذه التسويه موجوده هل هذه
الاشخاص الموجوده في الحكم تستطيع ان تقوم
بهذه التسويه خاصه هنا في اوروبا عندما
يتعلق الامر بالشعور بالبرد في الشتاء لا
حدث يتعاطف اي احد عندما يتعلق الامر
بالمساس بالغذاء نفس المشكله
الازمات بصراحه
وانا شخصيا
اي تصوير في اقرب وقت يعني
لن يتوقف على اوكرانيا اليوم اوكرانيا
وبعد بكره كازاخستان بعد بكره البولندا
والف شهيه عن دروشه هي ضخمه الروسيه
بصراحه
لا تريد العوده الى الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق
نعم ولكن نحن كما يشاهدنا على المناطق
المحتله وخاصه في خرصون بان روسيا رجعت
هناك تماثيلز وعمار صوفيا حتى في بعده
الاحيان دروس ركبوا هناك
العالم الصوفيين هذا صحيح
بدات تعاني في حياتها اليوميه ستحمل
المسؤوليه بالتاكيد ليه ليه ليه ليه روسيا
ولكن اذا يقول الابواب مسدوده
بصراحه عروسه تدريجيا انها تو فاشله التي
هذا خارطه علاوه داخل روسيا موجود
بين الجهاز الاندرويد
وزاره
بان نحن لن نجد في اقرب
وقت يعني انا روسيا تطلب اي اعتراف اراضي
المحتله الله من المستحيل فان نحن نصل
لماذا نحن حرب رؤوس
اشهر لماذا
شروط روسيه يعني ولكن من المنتظر بان
روسيا سوف تكون موافقه بان هي سوف
يرادوا وكرانيه الا شبه جزيره القرم فهل
مجتمع الاوكراني سوف تكون موافقه سوف يكون
موافقا للي اعتراف شبه جزيره القرم بانه
روسي انا اعطاك لا طيب ماذا ماذا عن ما
يتردد من قمه العشرين بنحتمال اللجوء الى
تشكيل نوع من لجنه حكما
والمقصود طبعا الصين فرنسا والسعوديه
لمحاوله لعب دور ماء واقتراح
خريطه الطريق ممكن ان تؤدي الى تقريب جهات
النظر ممكن المشكله
التوفيق هو من يستطيع من يريد ان يتنازل
هل اوكرانيا تستطيع ان تنازل وعندما اسمع
ضيفك من اوكرانيا واضح ان لدى الاوكران
نزعل قوميه قويه
يعني تكاثرت مع هذه الحرب وقويه مع هذه
الحرب المشكله اننا لا لا نتعاطفي السياسه
بالكره او بالحب هناك واقعيه هل نستطيع
حلول
الطريق انا براي ما يسعى اليه الرئيس
مكروه مايس عليه اليه حتى رئيس الصين لانه
الصين تلعب دور مهم لان الان وصلنا الى
كما قلنا في اوروبا هناك نقمه على هذه
الحرب لان ارتدادا اقتصاديه يوميا على
الدول هي مهمه وبنفس الوقت هناك من يقول
ان اوكرانيا حتى اللحظه لولا الدعم
الامريكي الذي يشكل اكثر من 90% بالمفهوم
العسكري لم تصمت ولكن لا تزال داخل
ومسميه هذه الروح الاوكرانيه روح المقاومه
في اوكرانيا لذلك انا برايي ال- ال- الدول
العشرين التي اصلا ل- يعني كانت يجب ان
تتعاطى بالمفهوم الاقتصادي سيست الموضوع
وكان الموضوع هو اوكرانيا وسبح للرئيس
الاوكراني بالقاء خطاب انا برايي اججج همم
موضوع ان يكون هناك هؤلاء الحكماء او هذه
الطريقه يعني يحكي الان عن هذا الموضوع او
الحل السويس بمعنى العوده الى ماذا كانت
تقول روسيا كانت تقول روسيا ان هناك
المتكلمين باللغه الروسيه مطبوعين كان
هناك ضدهم امور ونفهم ذلك هناك توثيق يعني
لا نريد ان ندخل بقال وقيل في هذا الموضوع
لذلك علينا ان نبحث باطار جديد بتوزيع ما
هي المهام التي نستطيع ان نقولها لهذه
الاقاليم ان كان في الدوباز او في خرسا او
في غيرها ولكن لا يجب ان نتعاطى مع القرم
لماذا لانه همم لا ننسى جميعا ان عندما
همم
بينا بالقرم ذهبنا الى كاس العالم لم يقل
احد ان ذلك غير طبيعي اذا كل كل العالم
قبل بذلك وذهب لبوتين يقول لها برافو عليك
ها نحن الان في كاس العالم في العام 1900
بال 2018 اذا الان هو البحث كيف وهذا يؤكد
لضيفك من من
يجب علينا ان نجد همم يعني قيادات
اوكرانيه لا تكون قيادات بمفهوم انها
تتراجع ولكن قيادات تستوعب الموضوع لكي لا
نصل الى الاسماء اكبر لاحقا برايك هناك في
موسكن فتاح على قبول هذا الثلاثي المطروح
اي شيء بينك
ومحمد بن سلمان
وعلى كل العلاقات
الروسيه الصينيه هي جيده العلاقات الروسيه
السعوديه جيده جدا
[موسيقى]
نعم هناك كان في سوء التفاهم خاصه
[ضحك]
بعد التفاصيل من وراء المفاوضات مع بوتين
موجود ما بين رئيس سيدنا
وتصريحات ماكرون كانت مهمه انا ضربت عدت
امثله حول عدم ازاله روسيا وضروره همم
الحديث معها كل هذا يرون في موسكو
يعتقدون ان فرنسا ممكن ان تلعب دورا في
هذا الشيء وليس فقط همم هذه الدول الثلاثه
همم هذيك المجموعه ممكن كنا اوسع من هذا
لانه تركيه تتوسط بشكل ناجح الان بالنسبه
لاتفاقيه الحبوب وبالنسبه لامور اخرى رغم
انه رغم انه تراك بعد الاحيان كانوا
يقولون انه شبه جزيره الكرمها هي لهم
هي للتتار اصلا اليس ذلك يا سيدتي
اليس اليسار كانوا يقيمون في هذه الجزيره
وهي ارض التتار
لا لا هناك قوميات عدي هو همم الان لا
يشكلون الاكثريه الاكثريه للناطقين باللغه
الروسيه ولكن هناك اوكران وتتعرى والروس
ولكن هي اصبحت جزء من همم امبراطوريه
الروسيه في ايام قيصر كثيرين الثانيه وهي
اخذت همم شبه جزيره القرم في في معارك
للقوات الروسيه همم
والنظر على القوميه الروسيه اتجاه شبه
جزيره العرب هي القويه جدا همم روسي
اعتقدون انه من هذاك الوقت
اصبح حتى روسيه وليست اوكرانيا
موقع استراتيجي للدخول لبحر ازوف ولذلك
عدد كبير من المنظرين في العسكر في
السياسه العسكريه او في السياسه الدفاعيه
الروسيه يرغبون دائما ان يكون هذا الممر
من البحر الاسود باتجاه ازوف بحر ازوف
وباتجاه القواعد البحريه ان كان للسفن
وكان للغواصات الروسيه ان تكون بعيده عن
الانظار ولذلك كان مهما وجد مهم للقوات
الروسيه ان تسيطر على كل ما نسميه ساحل
ازور طيبونديمير
الاسود
في اوكرانيا ان تداعيات هذه الحرب ربما
تؤثر على كثيرين بما في ذلك في الولايات
المتحده خاصه وان نسبه التضخم في ارتفاع
الركود الاقتصادي ايضا طال روسيا اليوم
حسب اخر الاحصائيات واطار ايضا الولايات
المتحده واوروبا اوروبا
من المراجعات لا
اولا نحاول اشوف الجزيره
على شعبه التاريخ
[موسيقى]
الهجري مره ثانيه ومره ثانيه
في الاتحاد
حاليا
هذا الشيء في مبادره بيني وبينك بيني
وبينك في كل مفاوضات في ياخذ وعطاء ما في
بس شروط تقبل وشروط اخرى ترفض يعني اخذ
عطاء
روسيا صوره شهرين هي سوف تكون موافقه على
كل على كل شروط اوكرانيه
على ماذا يعتمد هذا الكلام
شو عم تحكوا السقوط سقوط اخر الصوت هذا
بدايه نهايه
نظام بوتين هذا موهوب
لنا سقوط خرسا بدايه نهايه توتنهام
يقول انه هناك مشاكل في داخل روسيا غير
موجوده هذه المشاكل اذا كان هناك دمار فهو
دمار في اوكرانيا اوكرانيين لا يفهموا انه
استمرار هذه المواجهه همم مضر لهم ايضا
هذا يحضر بالتدمير لهم
ليش اني رافدين
كيف ممكن
المستحيل الصواريخ
استسلام
انا الولايات المتحده تدفع باتجاه الحرب
لتقسيم اوروبا
ولكن هذه النظريه اصبحت منتشره حتى بعد ما
قالت تكتب ذلك صحيح حتى يعني ضيفتك من
روسيه قالت الموضوع وقالت انه هناك اتفاق
امريكي روسي بدا بالاجتماع من المخابرات
الامريكيه والمخابرات الروسيه بتركيا
لموضوع له علاقه هم يقولوا بموضوع الاسلحه
النوويه واعاده
الاتفاقيات التي لها علاقه بالاسلحه
النوويه ولكن انا برايي اكيد تطرق الى
موضوع اوكرانيا وان موضوع الدعم العسكري
الذي
مع مع حضرتك صح تطرقوا لهذا الموضوع اكيد
الخطوره الخطوره يا صديقتي ان عندما يتفق
ان تتفق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
روسيا هناك من سيدفع الثمن والذي سيدفع
الثمن هم الاوكران وان اذا تريد اوكرانيا
ان تدفع الثمن والخوف هو
لن يذهب بعيدا هناك جاليه اوكرانيه مهمه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك ضباط
في الجيش الامريكي من اصول اوكران استثمر
في قداس في ساحل البحر الاسود والكل
يعرفههم وهم الذين يدفعون الى مرحله ما
الاستعاده هذه الخساره الماديه التي
خسروها هناك هذا مفهوم ولكن بنفس الوقت
ماذا تقدم
روسيا ماذا تقدم هل تقدم روسيا من يوم
لاخر همم تمطر اوكرانيا بالصواريخ هذا غير
معقول يجب ان نجد وسيله اخرى بالتعاطي
سمعنا ان حتى السيد اوربان البارحه الذي
ذهب ليجمع مجلس دفاع بعد س هذا الصاروخ في
بولونيا
هو الوحيد تحدثت عنهربان هو وصف تصريحات
زينسكي بانها غير مسؤوله بما يتعلق بتحميل
معه خوف بان الصاروخ نسبيا معه حق بمعنى
انه يوري الكل يريد الحقيقه ولكن هذه
الحقيقه قد تزعج الاخرين بنفس الوقت عندما
تكلمنا عن القنبله الوسخه ماذا قيل للسيد
جيلنسكي ذهبت امريكا وذهبت اوروبا بالقول
انتبه ان اي عمل بهذا الموضوع قد يدعك قد
بدل ان تكون انت الضحيه ستصبح المجرم يعني
هناك تبادل انا برايي الطرح الان هل هناك
قيادات داخل اوكرانيا تستطيع ان تتعاطى
انا لا اقول ان غدا سيذهب زكي ابدا
الموضوع هو هل توجد قيادات منفتحه مع
روسيا لما حتى اللحظه لا يوجد في روسيا اي
خلل بمفهوم الهرم الاداري او الهرم الهرم
الهرم الذي يعطي الاوامر لا يزال بوتين
يهزا بالجميع ولا يريد ان يعني رجل قوته
تركت خرسه منذ 10 ايام وهو لا يتكلم عن
سعر السيارات بروسيا يعني بعيد عن الموضوع
لا يريد ان يدخل هو بعيد عن هذا الموضوع
الذي هو انتهجه هو وراءه لذلك الان الحديث
عن اطار حكماء
طبيعي لقد نسينا تركيا وشكرا لضيفتك من
روسيا تذكرنا بتوري تركيا لان تركيا الان
هو شرطي البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
التي تاتي من من اوكرانيا ومن روسيا
باتجاه الدول التي هي محتاجه وبنفس الوقت
هو يدخل على اطار كبير مقبول من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مقبول من الرئيس بوتين
وحتى اتفق هو المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالمفهوم الاسلامي اي اصبح له وجودا اكثر
مما نعطيه الان بالنسبه لدوله تركيا وهو
يستطيع ان يكون يعني حلقه حوار مع
الاوكران ولكن انا باعتقادي حتى اللحظه لا
يوجد داخل اوكرانيا هذه القيادات المطلوبه
انا لا اريد ان يوصف بالجبناء او يوصف
بالاشخاص الذين يعني سيتركون وطنهم ابدا
ولكن الموضوع نحن بحاجه الى حل هذا الوضع
الحالي يمكن ان يفرز قيادات من هذا النوع
الذي تحدث عنه همم طارق وهبي هنا في
الاستديو
روسيا كانت تتمنى لك صراحه لانه روسيا
اكيد لا ترى في ذا لانسكي رئيسا ممكن يتخذ
قرارات صعبه لحتى الان القيادي الاوكرانيه
الحاليه ليست لديها اراده سياسيه
ومشكله انه اوكرانيا
ايوه هناك اكثر من قضيه قضيه فساد
حكومات كانت تتغير بسرعه نعم اوكرانيا
بحاجه لقائد ممكن ان يكون عقلاني وممكن ان
تتبلور عنده اراده سياسيه حقيقيه
نعم يدخل مفاوضات صعبه
طيب هنادي امير هناك هذه العقليه في
اوكرانيا اليوم
بكره سوف يكون موافقه
مفاوضات مع روسيا مجتمع اوكرانيا
اتمنى ذلك
شكرا
فريق البرنامج
[موسيقى]